what if I told you that the life mission
of one of the most celebrated content
creators in Rainbow six siege was to
break it what I like to do is throw an
impact grenade at those little garbage
cans then you will be able to lie down
and crawl right and to employ a mixture
of genius deceit and destruction to
school his opponents in the most
infuriating ways imaginable it's gonna
start working his way out here as well
but over the years coconut raw has
solidified himself as something of a
cult figure okay he's gone from a quirky
youtuber who's driven others to think
outside the box to see just very own
godfather of cheese he's even like kind
of like an inside joke in the pro scene
it's like like oh this guy's been
watching too many coconut bra videos
whenever something weird happens were
like somebody watched a coconut bra
video through his never-ending quest for
so-called honest exploits coconut bra
has changed the way that Siege heads
approach their craft he's earned the
respect of the community he's like a mad
scientist of this game man he's wormed
his way into the literal highest level
of play I can tell you pro players
literally use his videos and she's
ignited a balance war with Ubisoft but
contrary to what you might think coconut
bra isn't some toxic [ __ ] who gets
off on watching the Siege community tear
itself apart he isn't trying to piss
people off he's trying to educate them
to make those who claim to love this
game as much as he does well smarter
okay so you've probably noticed that the
show looks a little bit different this
week
that's because here at the score we're
taking every precaution against the Cova
19 pandemic but rest assured even though
we're all working from home we're still
going to be delivering the same great
eSports content that you've come to
expect okay so who exactly is coconut
bra how did he become the most
infuriating source of ingenuity Siege
has ever seen and why the hell do all of
this games content creators have
brassiere related releases yes well for
a long time people didn't actually know
who he was since he never did a face
reveal they just assumed he was some
kind of evil mastermind well actually I
am coconut bra undercover ladies and
gentlemen we got him memes aside coconut
bra isn't some maniacal troll this is
him his name is John and he's a regular
guy who happens to be one of the biggest
sweetheart since each it's for you man
yeah yeah Merry Christmas
he just also happens to have an
unquenchable thirst for exploits or what
he favourably refers to as alternate
methods so where did he get his start
well it wasn't in siege coconut and the
cult thereof all began thanks to a
destined loss it all started because
there's really difficult bosses when
you're low level right so me and my
friend we just like randomly stumbled
upon a really like weird angle to be
able to shoot a boss in destiny but it
was something cool that nobody's seen
before so I posted on the forums people
liked it they thought it was awesome the
problem is that destiny wasn't
competitive it was just man versus code
coconut was spending all of his time
outsmarting a game a system and that
became tiresome but his hunger for a new
challenge was finally satisfied when he
first discovered sheesh when seeds came
out I saw the trailer for it I it looked
like a hardcore like Search and Destroy
counter-strike type of thing I knew was
something I had to
right and then as soon as I played seeds
for the first time it was just like you
fall down that rabbit hole of
information where there's endless things
to learn ceej offered coconut the chance
to outsmart not just a game engine but
those who engaged with it
he wasn't just out braining AI bullet
sponges anymore he was mentally out
dueling living grieving opponents and
because of how tactical intense and
generally raw siege was there were very
few people taking that kind of weird
zany approach to it I remember when I
first started youtubing procedure I
would watch a lot of like serenity 17
and Macey J and yeah I could just tell
like they're crazy good at aiming yes
but at the same time they would outplay
people that are also really good at
aiming because they're smart or they
think of something that nobody's thought
of they go for something else so that's
why I've seen so much is there's no way
I'm gonna walk in the room and flick to
five people I'm not that good naturally
but I tend to think about the game very
differently than a lot of people and
luckily for me people think that's
interesting to watch so I like sharing
the information what is up you guys
welcome back and in this video we are
gonna go over what is in my opinion the
top 10 spawn kill points it's gonna go
over all various maps see that's the
beautiful and awful thing about siege
it's inherently cheesy from run-outs to
spawn peaks to the myriad of ways in
which destruction can spell both you and
your opponents undoing siege is the kind
of game where it's actually really easy
to kill someone who's way better than
you
[Music]
very circus I mean can somebody check
they're so fast that was so fast he
really goes in and like exploits that
destruction system a lot of the time and
I really love that like it really helps
siege besiege you know we use that
destruction system we use the gadgets
and we get those crazy angles it's it is
what seeds is about you don't need the
insane name like you can get a kill on
bolo by not having to take a gunfight
with them that's a lot of damage
incurred there from just some leads and
traps and he's gonna continue to not
check and incur even more damage from
for total Legion comes out Oh 50 HP and
the gas canisters are gonna chip away
with the c4 to add to it bolo doesn't
get to play the round
unlike Counter Strike siege didn't
require you to be an aim God to win and
for coconut that's what made it so great
you could legitimately fury craft your
way to success I'm not that good like I
can't just run into a site and like you
know lean five times and spray four
people down like that I'll probably
never be able to do that I've always
looked for alternative methods to do
things I don't ever want to get into
like any type of glitches or anything I
look for like unorthodox ways to bring
success to things that are acceptable
and just ways that people are like oh I
never thought about that
now you need to understand coconut
wasn't just your average spawn peaking
douchenozzle sea just filled with those
no this guy was a super special breed of
[ __ ] the kind of opponent who made
you question why you played this game in
the first place what is there Wesley
there
thank you but because his tips and
tricks were so effective it wasn't long
before he started gaining notoriety and
since then he's collated thousands of
strats from a variety of sources ranked
pro league and his discord community and
watched as they worm their way into
nearly every level of play I watch all
of his videos because if I don't I'm
gonna get spawn Pete's from every single
angle actually was funny we were playing
in the content creator Cup and I'm
rappelling down like the rafters and I'm
like I'm gonna die - coconut running out
on some ridiculous thing I called it as
some [ __ ] spawn think I don't have
been knowing into this bike coconut I'm
dead alright I literally I literally
called it - it's more along the lines of
like wow that was like I didn't think I
didn't know you could do that whereas
like normally when I get mad it's like
why did you do that right it's the
annoying situations are what make me mad
when I die to other stuff it's like wow
I just didn't even know that existed
that's just impressive like I learned
something new today the funny thing is
that despite dishing out some truly BM
beatdowns
coconut and his legion of bras yes he
refers to his community as bras
what is that bras what is up bras what
is up bras what is up bras what is up
bras what is up bras what is that what
was I say oh yeah in spite of everything
coconut isn't actually all that in the
line it's as if his [ __ ] is simply -
mesmerizing to hate but that's not to
say that he's never being criticized
over the years a lot of salty silvers
have downplayed or disregarded the
usefulness of coconuts so called rat
strats and these imagination --less
plebs couldn't have been further from
the truth you do watch them you can
learn some stuff like some like we call
it rat stuff but like you can learn
interesting things like new run-outs you
spawn Peaks I have tried to use some so
of my teammates so
he does impact in like weird ways like
even pro like pro league players are
definitely using his stuff
I like his videos he shows a lot of you
know cool unique tricks that a lot of
people even most pros don't really know
and like I've given respect I don't know
how some of the spots that he finds like
how he finds them but they help you know
I've used some of them I know he's
personally taking something from like
you know our Pro League matches he's
asked if it's ok he's very generous and
respectful and I think he's like really
really nice and a really good content
creator for the community but coconuts
single most infamous contribution to Pro
play is something called purple tarps a
form of mat parkour that allowed
attackers to gain an elevated angle on
one of coastlines strongest sites but
here's the thing
purple tarps wasn't just some nifty
little offing you could coordinating
tire strategies around this maneuver
basically making it a [ __ ] meta in
and of itself before long purple tarps
became core to virtually any form of
high-level play on coastline the only
drawback was that well it was kind of a
pain in the ass to execute by the way
this is the here's how you do it thank
you for the lesson laxing so I'm sure at
some point Ubisoft will add like an
invisible player while it takes it takes
a practice one utility lay to him not
the most graceful laxing out there but
he gets it taught from his mother at a
young age able to climb up the top and
with it prosperity and that was
intentional see even though the
community loved purple tarps Ubisoft not
so much they would patch it out and
within no time coconut would find a new
way to get up there I'm sorry Ubisoft
please still invite me to the seasonal
preview events now we got another way to
get on the coastline purple tarps and
this one this one's even easier and you
can do it literally three steps from
your spawn and pre-fire the hookah
window within literal seconds of the
round starting it even got to the point
where coconut basically became the bane
of restocks existence boom boom boom
sorry Ubisoft
you mad at me but as far as pro players
were concerned the man was doing God's
work when the purple tarp was the thing
on coastline and they kept patching and
patching it every day we would like we'd
hop on four scrimps would be like the
coconut brown like did he find the new
way like we need to know because they
just patched a new one he's like did you
find the new way on the turf yet and
she'll be like yeah I got the video and
he's Lincoln we literally like we would
use it too just so we knew how to get on
the park tarps tow remember waxing from
that earlier clip here's how you do it
well he used purple tarps to close out
one of the biggest upsets in six
invitational history you're waxing out
on the tarp it's a 2 B 3 it's a 1 V 3
Canadian to keep his team alive than the
biggest tournament in the world turn to
the corner he grabs one on the mark
trying to go in for two against Fox a
launch date Allah will take his two
bullets close right through the deagle
deagle sit down 1v1 against laxing relax
the odds are
evil geniuses eventually after patching
out every known way of getting up there
who be soft just gave up and made the
tarp incapable of being traversed but
that didn't stop coconut from getting
the last lash I actually have another
way to get out there but now because the
tarps are transparent it's not viable
and it takes a long time so it wouldn't
be that good anyways but it is funny
because I still can get up there because
ultimately that's what coconut and his
army of bras are all about chasing
cherishing and championing the things
that make siege well siege and look say
what you will about the man his [ __ ]
works
Oh No Oh coconut the angles man oh just
a little there you go he's got it lined
up he'll do it like way more than it
should working his way out here as well
but
the angles more importantly he's
inspired his legions of fans to pride
themselves on being able to think
outside the box to prioritize
intelligence over eight
make no mistake while coconut bra might
be a little bit of a terror he's raised
the collective IQ of the entire sea
changer at the end of the day that's a
good thing it's really cool knowing that
I inspired that because there's so many
different minds that come together in a
way that also is like what helps people
evolve in the game and I think a lot of
other community members are like-minded
like that how did he become the most
infuriating source of ingenuity Siege
has ever seen and why the hell do all of
this games content creators have
Brasseur related aliases oh yeah [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] you monster knew you were
gonna say it but you know you didn't
have didn't have to rub it all right